good morning or good evening George Ann
how are you nice and fine thanks and you
not too bad
normally we speak in Romanian in fact I
don't think we spoke in more than 30
seconds in English but I wanted to begin
I wanted to begin the discussion in
English by because a lot of people of
course don't understand Romanian and
soon we will start speaking in Romanian
but I guess about two months ago I
contacted you through Elance and you
translated however 100 or so sentences
and recorded them for me and that was
more or less the beginning of my
Romanian language learning adventure and
then the last month or so we spoke via
Skype a few times a week and all in
preparation for my trip to Romania and
so I just want to point out that there
are these resources like me Lance
which introduce you to very capable
people and that the Romanians that I
have met you and the others that I met
through Elance and the ones that I met
in Romania have really made a very
favorable impression on me a very high
level of English very capable friendly
lots of initiative so all in all have a
very favorable impression of Romania but
you of course live in Austria right when
you graduated from university in Sibiu
or clued in cluj-napoca yes the Faculty
of Letters faculty a blender and the
services that you provide over Elance is
basically translated right yes English
Romanian French no shifting is Romanian
English French Romanian maybe Spanish -
Romanian very good all right so that's
just an introduce the subject and now I
will try to speak my Romanian and we can
talk about
anything my experience in Romania also
also for beam and in Rome honesty
mium me up Lockwood portable obesity and
Romania I first a first good real good
dad
a first plucky the amplitude would the
one day I first prime adapter and
cherish
um I'm Veneto I'm applica la rattles
bring us tea petrichor I'm forced in
Vienna in Austria a crazy lay aa do PO
che I'm Dom I'm like at La Redoute
spring Bucharest a ah I'm so chic
Ryker so she hears you on doctor ah
mythology I'm visit at a fabrica the
Christian she all Manistee yeah I put me
to the managed a punchy Tori for beat
doe ar-rahman st i'm i'm in to put
several best romanized in Vienna
petrichor I'm first Endicott la
littérature
in adjuster adjust pituitary
a vo woman ding-ding mud itself and
could bring the Roman here and took up a
era of the treachery a pen through woman
debauchery and domain ela Landry I'm a
my intern II um I'm gassy romani
a pencil petrichor a duper door doing
the invit sorry
Roman ester am brute support bass I'm
gassy or Massa one day era do are Roman
II am in Chapel support best a cuckoo
Lord
no look look for you Kui Kui ah era 40%
petrichor kun one deeply I just a woman
era free model partially you know Raj
you know rationally in Moldova current
semester combination combination ominous
yeah primero are insisted l knew our new
our fee subtract labraccio in into de
instead if you still down and Judah
traveler traveler
supplying co-managed yes let Rebecca
managed yester of fabrica um yeah I just
accompany it
I'm uh turret sister skim skim plant
lanolin lanolin young relief and I'm a
master a master combination and I was
the fourth entry supported lesson yes
the long fourth kalos fourth Platanos a
force apart the experience sake ahmad da
da and in romania dupa reduce pendulum
in Kiryat Messina in Romania darker
darker one lot a lot iced tea plantation
dosage the arrow a pot a Yahoo chauffeur
mmm at launch cool chauffeur and some
más dinero dose a la combination chassis
the
color Toria I am bored I am bored though
are Romanist
the job for best my being a domination
guarantee about a water bath can be my
[ __ ] that could I could I mean to put
into my Vinny
Bravo this pair spare ah
do paço manage co-manage a mess ring
mood bring ya [ __ ] out yet announced
not on yachts clean 40 promos month a
lot answer Vanya nah um please artists
Kimba thought Xin zhe tequila me then
insolence
um I'm 40 though I Romanesque a good
shopper of course I'm visited sickish
wanna a tuple Sagrada see you in Sydney
a via a via or festival a festival or a
goon festival festival the TR stress a
bullet a strands the rope streets ten
minutes Drusilla ah
our first lien the woman now ha era our
first oh how do you say 40 Peter knows
could cut or cut the data in Kannada
Dhaka is 40-volt woman in Brazil a a
support area problema canary current
build he she a such a problem dark
Bramalea in Sibiu meet you no money
Thank You means so who means Gomi Gomi
huh
well behaved well behaved da da da da
[ __ ] no I might fosston brush-off vent
Roker do are I'm a would do it
go easy lay please Allah praise Allah
wounds in a pen to fortunate at Oh
easily they continued control visita a
visitor no harm abu dharr disabled
riyadh senator st. working romania some
old mood lock launch now please local
and carry a real say civil shop
bucharest lift ill cluj-napoca alba
iulia
timmy shuara kk i am i am come para o
carton display romania kissing new mesh
today they chased a romania outfit the
loot young boy ambos Atilla last video
pollutant ah um the
today better a yes day Oh Oh Carter ah
poutine poutine negative critic display
Romania die
Oh impressive am Abood yes take a
Romania yester hot sauna thinner pen
trucker the longer longer premier I
would know new our first independent
force a sub control touchy
austro-hungarian Usha ah
I'm impressed impression or impress
brush right yeah
impressive I'm impressed come yesterday
Oh Tara carrot sir in Chapel I say Salta
there's not this what up this that okay
soon multi possibility' Illuma is the
most positive
ah this evil Akuma multi the an an
alphabet ism era
distilled liquor na da a come of all
evil Oh the eventual yesterday stood
there D theta
ah you many a new mood experienced a
coup democracia a [ __ ]
yesterday Tim pop and to this guitar
that soon what optimist and true Sonia
what a minute
Romani don't don't be a pessimist ah
eternal or a woman kuqali
I'm a booty relax ill a suit or of
posture they stood a positive okay I
will stop it here I just wanted to have
this brief presentation about Romania
and we'll do the the subtitle so thank
you I will stop the recording